almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it one of the
great tragedies of the Trump
administration is that almost everything
rather than mostly everything is pure
politics
it's just sport its wins and losses it's
blame and credit and this applies as
well to the cool virus dance party as
some people suggested we call it to
avoid D monetization for talking about
it and Donald Trump is now blaming the
Obama administration for the Trump
administration's response to the virus
check this out one of the things that
we've learned is that the u.s. is barely
doing any testing for it if you're not
sick enough to have to be hospitalized
in many cases even if you're suspected
of having it having the symptoms you
often aren't tested and the effect of
this of course is that the reported
number of cases in the United States is
likely drastically understating the
number of real cases and if you don't
get a positive test result and you
actually do have it you are more likely
to go out in public
possibly infect others if you think you
don't have it then someone who knows
that they have it and is more likely to
go may go home and self-quarantine
Donald Trump is blaming the lack of
testing on Barack Obama take a look at
this you just want to add like mine
and to go a little bit further the Obama
administration made a decision on
testing and that turned out to be very
detrimental to what we're doing and we
undid that decision a few days ago so
that the testing can take place in a
much more accurate and rapid fashion
that was the decision we disagreed with
I don't think we would have made it but
for some reason it was
but we've undone that decision also when
people come in from certain areas we're
doing checks not only at the site of
takeoff but at the site of landing so
when they land in our country we'll also
do this if the planes are leaving from
certain destinations so nobody in the
room seemingly with any idea what Donald
Trump is talking about a decision Obama
made and Trump undid it so a reporter
did the right thing and followed up and
said what what rule are you talking
about what is this about Obama now and
Mike Pence who's leading this entire
fiasco says oh yeah yeah yeah
FDA jurisdiction something something mr.
president you mentioned Obama era rule
that you have changed regarding this
virus I didn't follow that well let's
talk about it we could talk about Bob
Bob Redfield you might speak about the
last administration asserted FDA
jurisdiction over testing and the
development of tests like this above
President changed that on Saturday so
there now as I spoke to several
governors this morning states now have
the ability to actually conduct the
coronavirus test in State labs
university laboratories inhibits and
that that's because of the change the
president authorized right because of
Obama States couldn't test or is it they
couldn't develop tests or with
laboratories you know what is it
universities this is gas lighting Donald
Trump disbanded the pandemic response
team Donald Trump gutted funding to the
CDC Donald Trump resisted treating this
seriously for weeks and not if not
months and continues to do so and as far
as the claim about the FDA an aide to
Republican senator Lamar Alexander said
the Obama administration didn't do
anything
Obama proposed giving the FDA more
oversight over some tests it didn't go
through the truth that Donald Trump
won't tell you is that his CDC made a
mistake they tried to create their own
tests instead of accepting the test
that's been made available by the World
Health Organization the CDC test failed
and now we're in a situation where we
don't even know how many cases we have
it almost take
some skill some creativity or at least
some malignant narcissism to make this
even somehow about Barack Obama
you know blaming the last guy for debt
or unemployment numbers it's at least
theoretically viable blaming the last
guy three years into your presidency for
your response to a pandemic threat would
only work on I guess exactly the types
of people who think Donald Trump is
doing a great job I would go further
weren't the testing forms in Hillary's
emails which she bleached an acid-wash
to offer her private server let go even
further and meanwhile they say we don't
want to politicize this the way
Democrats are politicizing the virus and
while we're on this topic don't forget
how the anti Obama people in 2014 were
reacting to Obama's handling of Ebola
which of course ended up not becoming a
global pandemic and about which all
conversation simply stopped the day
after the 2014 midterms Republicans
would have had you think we had a
domestic crisis on our hands in the
United States thanks to Barack Obama on
Ebola right up until the day of the 2014
midterms at which point we barely heard
a word about Ebola again but they don't
want what's going on now politicized by
Democrats it's pathetic it's disgusting
and it's leading to more people being
sick this is not a joke
this is not did I increase or decrease
the deficit this is life and death and
it's absolutely disgusting